This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the early 1950s, Sam Moore and his family left rural Arkansas looking to start a new life. They planned on moving to Chicago. We were on our way to Chicago with all our worldly possession and our dog's spot. And we started off in my granddad, his 53-dynofBewitt and got the St. Louis and ran out of gas. And instead of continuing on to Illinois, Moore's family just decided to stay. They settled in a middle-class area called theville. Back then St. Louis was segregated and theville was one of the only African-American neighborhoods in the city.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。20世纪50年代初，萨姆·摩尔和他的家人离开阿肯色州的农村，寻求开始新的生活。他们计划搬到芝加哥。“我们带着所有的家当和我们的狗Spot在去芝加哥的路上。我们开着我祖父那辆53年的德索托（DeSoto）出发，到了圣路易斯时没油了。”他们没有继续前往伊利诺伊州，而是决定留在圣路易斯。他们在维尔（The Ville）这个中产阶级社区定居下来。当时圣路易斯实行种族隔离，而维尔是城里仅有的几个非裔美国人社区之一。
But residents of theville made the best of it. That's reporter Zach Dyer. Black owned businesses thrived and the neighborhood became one of theville made the best of it. That's reporter Zach Dyer. Black owned businesses thrived, and the neighborhood became one of the most prosperous African-American communities in the country. Do you mind if we just roll the windows up just for the recording? Okay, I turn the air on. Sam Moore's dad got a job as a brick layer, and helped build some of the beautiful, stately brick homes in this area. He was a great brick layer. He did quite a few jobs around this town. I still see some of the beautiful, stately brick homes in this area. He was a great bricklay. He did quite a few jobs around this town.
但维尔的居民充分利用了这里的条件。这是记者扎克·戴尔。黑人拥有的企业蓬勃发展，该社区成为了全国最繁荣的非裔美国人社区之一。“你介意我们为了录音把车窗摇上去吗？好的，我把空调打开。”萨姆·摩尔的父亲找了一份泥瓦匠的工作，帮助建造了这个地区一些漂亮、庄严的砖房。“他是一位出色的泥瓦匠。他在这个镇上做了不少工作。我仍然能看到一些……”
I still see some of my dads work. Oh wow, really. Mm-hmm. It was a beautiful homes, triple brick, three story, two story buildings. It will cost a million dollars to duplicate. The driving around the village today, where Moore has lived for almost his entire life and is now the alderman, the neighborhood looks very different.
“我仍然能看到一些我父亲的作品。”“哦，哇，真的吗？”“嗯。那是些漂亮的房子，三层砖结构，三层楼、两层楼的建筑。现在要复制它们得花上一百万美元。”今天开车在维尔转悠，摩尔几乎一生都住在这里，现在是市议员，这个社区看起来大不相同了。
We pull up in front of a couple of old houses. One on one second. Look at these two buildings. Look at that building. You can see clean through it. From the street, the building's facade looks normal. It's a two-story brick home sitting on a white limestone base. Rounded brick arches frame the first four windows,
我们停在几栋老房子前。“等一下。看看这两栋建筑。看看那栋楼。你可以直接看穿它。”从街上看，建筑的立面看起来很正常。这是一栋两层高的砖房，坐落在白色的石灰岩基座上。圆形的砖拱门框住了第一层的四扇窗户，
but head just around the corner and you can see that the entire side wall is missing. The bricks are just gone. You can see straight into the rooms, each with a different wallpaper. We call them die houses because you can look inside of them and see what's going on. Remember when the little girls play with the die houses, you put the furniture in, you can see it and you put your hand in the wall. In the past 50 years, the city of St. Louis has lost more than half its population. Vacancy has skyrocketed in the village and other neighborhoods on the north side. Entire neighborhoods here are just green pasture, punctuated by the occasional dilapidated building
但转过拐角，你会发现整面侧墙都不见了。砖块完全消失了。你可以直接看到房间内部，每个房间都有不同的壁纸。“我们称它们为‘玩偶屋’，因为你可以往里看，看到里面发生了什么。记得小女孩玩玩偶屋的时候吗？你把家具放进去，你能看到它，你还能把手伸进墙里。”在过去的50年里，圣路易斯市失去了超过一半的人口。维尔和其他北区社区的空置率飙升。这里的整个街区只剩下绿色的草地，偶尔点缀着几栋破败的建筑，
that slowly surrendering to the landscape around it. When Moore became an alderman back in 2007, he started to get calls from his constituents complaining about these collapsing buildings. So he set out to discover why they were falling down. He figured it was probably just because they were so old. But then he noticed that something was strange about these so-called doll houses. They were surrounded by piles of broken bricks and debris, but something was missing.
它们正慢慢向周围的景观屈服。当摩尔在2007年成为市议员时，他开始接到选民的电话，抱怨这些正在倒塌的建筑。于是他着手调查它们倒塌的原因。他以为可能只是因为它们太老了。但随后他注意到这些所谓的“玩偶屋”有些奇怪。它们周围堆满了碎砖和瓦砾，但少了点什么。
I often wondered why. I never saw whole bricks. If the buildings were falling down into piles, but there weren't any whole bricks in those piles, more knew it meant someone was taking them. Salvatge bricks are valuable. There's a market for them, just like there's a market for the copper that gets stripped out of old homes. A pickup truck full of old bricks could be worth upwards of $300.
“我经常想为什么。我从来没见过完整的砖块。”如果建筑倒塌成堆，但堆里没有完整的砖块，摩尔知道这意味着有人把它们拿走了。回收的砖块很有价值。它们有市场，就像从旧房子里拆出来的铜线有市场一样。一辆装满旧砖的皮卡车价值可能超过300美元。
But these bricks weren't being salvaged legally. There was a not legal demolition projects that were theft. It was brick theft. And this theft was happening on a massive scale in Mord's district. Well, I have 1242 empty buildings and 1700 vacant lots. So out of the 1700 vacant lots, I guarantee you that 1200 of them will stolen. And despite these being vacant houses, all of this brick theft is a problem. When a building's bricks get stolen, the house usually can't be resold. It also takes money out of the pockets of legal demolition workers.
但这些砖块并不是合法回收的。有一些非法的拆除项目其实是盗窃。这是砖块盗窃。这种盗窃在摩尔的选区大规模发生。“我有1242栋空置建筑和1700块空地。所以在那1700块空地中，我敢保证其中1200块是被偷走的。”尽管这些是空置房屋，但所有的砖块盗窃都是一个问题。当一栋建筑的砖块被偷走时，房子通常就无法再转售了。这也从合法的拆除工人手中抢走了钱。
And it stalls redevelopment because you can't sell a building when you can't guarantee that it'll be there next week. But there's also something intangible that's lost with Brick theft. The villa's been home to famous African-Americans like Chuck Berry, Tina Turner, and the opera singer Grace Bumbry. I remember the Grace Bumbry house. That house was stolen. And they just called them old raggedy buildings,
而且它阻碍了重建，因为如果你不能保证一栋建筑下周还在那里，你就无法出售它。但砖块盗窃还导致了一些无形东西的流失。维尔曾是查克·贝里、蒂娜·特纳和歌剧演唱家格蕾丝·邦布里等著名非裔美国人的家。“我记得格蕾丝·邦布里的房子。那栋房子被偷了。”他们只是称它们为破旧的建筑，
but a lot of our history was taken away in stone as well. Brick theft has been going on all across St. Louis since at least the 1970s. Whole buildings, whole blocks, whole parts of neighborhoods being stolen, carted off illegally, and sold. How and where in the United States can somebody steal a whole building and not get caught? St. Louis's history with bricks starts back in 1849 when a boat fire on the riverfront jumped into the city. Hundreds of wooden buildings along the river burned the ground.
但我们许多历史也随着石头一起被带走了。砖块盗窃自20世纪70年代以来一直在圣路易斯各地发生。整栋建筑、整个街区、社区的整个部分被偷走、非法运走并出售。在美国，一个人怎么可能偷走整栋建筑而不被抓住？圣路易斯与砖块的历史始于1849年，当时河滨的一场船火蔓延到了城市。河边数百栋木制建筑被烧毁。
The fire's devastation led the city government to order that all new buildings be constructed with fireproof materials. Luckily, the city happened to be sitting on top of a lot of high-quality clay, as well as the coal that would be needed to fire the kilns to turn that clay into brick. Well, I could show you a couple of these different kinds of bricks. One thing that I think is interesting is that Andrew Wiles is the executive director of the landmarks association of St. Louis. Behind his desk, he's got a giant frame pictorial map of the city back in the late 1800s. The landscape is dotted with evidence of the city's once thriving brick industry.
火灾的破坏导致市政府下令所有新建筑必须使用防火材料建造。幸运的是，这座城市恰好坐落在大量优质粘土之上，还有烧制这些粘土所需的煤炭。“好吧，我可以给你看几种不同的砖块。我认为有趣的一点是……”安德鲁·怀尔斯是圣路易斯地标协会的执行董事。在他的办公桌后面，挂着一张巨大的19世纪末城市画报地图。景观中点缀着这座城市曾经繁荣的砖业的证据。
It's covered with mines and smoke stacks. You'll see some smoke stacks and you'll see some sort of derrick set up or winches set up over mines. Some pit mines, you'll also see these beehive kilns, they look like big igloos. The red clay industry was so big that folks were even digging mines in their backyard to get this stuff. And all this new industry attracted others to St. Louis. In the decades
它布满了矿井和烟囱。“你会看到一些烟囱，还会看到一些架设在矿井上的井架或绞车。一些露天矿，你还会看到这些蜂巢窑，它们看起来像巨大的冰屋。”红粘土工业规模如此之大，以至于人们甚至在后院挖矿来获取这种材料。所有这些新兴工业吸引了其他人来到圣路易斯。在接下来的几十年里，
to come, waves of migrants from across Europe and the southern US flocked to the city. It was a boom town. So it's sort of a perfect storm of materials, labor, and industrial innovation that combined to make St. Louis into his brick producing powerhouse. By 1890, St. Louis was home to the world's largest brick manufacturing company. Millions of bricks were exported across the country to build skyscrapers in Chicago and other buildings across the Western and Southern United States. Bricks were cheap and plentiful. And that meant that even modest working-class homes in St. Louis could have one of a kind of brick work. They're not just blank facades.
来自欧洲和美国南部的移民潮涌向这座城市。这是一个繁荣的城镇。所以这是一种材料、劳动力和工业创新的完美风暴，结合在一起使圣路易斯成为了砖块生产的强国。到1890年，圣路易斯拥有世界上最大的砖块制造公司。数以百万计的砖块被出口到全国各地，用于建造芝加哥的摩天大楼以及美国西部和南部的其他建筑。砖块便宜且充足。这意味着即使是圣路易斯普通的工人阶级住宅也可以拥有独一无二的砖砌工艺。它们不仅仅是空白的立面。
They have this sort of corbling or extensions or recesses and ornamental bricks built into them, pressed flowers or designs and string courses and things like that. But even as these beautiful brick homes were going up all across the city, the conditions for the city's eventual semi-abandonment were also being put into place. In the early 1900s, St. Louis was forcing its black citizens to live in segregated neighborhoods. When the practice was found unconstitutional, realtors began asking homeowners in St. Louis to sign something called race-restrictive deed covenants. These barred the homeowner and future homeowners from selling the
“它们有这种叠涩、延伸或凹槽，以及装饰性的砖块嵌入其中，压制的图案或设计、腰线之类的东西。”但即使这些美丽的砖房在城市各处拔地而起，城市最终半荒废的条件也正在形成。20世纪初，圣路易斯强迫其黑人公民居住在隔离的社区。当这种做法被裁定违宪时，房地产经纪人开始要求圣路易斯的房主签署所谓的“种族限制契约”。这些契约禁止房主和未来的房主将
property to African-Americans and other minority groups. Here's Colin Gordon, a history professor at the University of Iowa. When Realtors assessed properties for sale in St. Louis, you know, well into the 1960s, one of the standard items on the assessment form was the nearest Negro community, or the degree to which Negroes had invaded or intruded upon a neighborhood. And is invasion a word that was used in these documents? Oh yeah, these were the words that were used. Intrusion, invasion, and the like. Not only were African Americans blocked from certain neighborhoods by these racist deed
房产出售给非裔美国人和其他少数群体。这是爱荷华大学的历史学教授科林·戈登。“当房地产经纪人评估圣路易斯的待售房产时，你知道，一直到20世纪60年代，评估表上的标准项目之一就是‘最近的黑人社区’，或者黑人入侵或闯入一个社区的程度。”“‘入侵’是这些文件中使用的词吗？”“哦，是的，这些就是所使用的词。入侵、闯入等等。”非裔美国人不仅被这些种族主义契约挡在某些社区之外，
covenants, the city was also bulldozing black neighborhoods for massive new projects like the Gateway Arch. This was the age of urban renewal. Increasingly, we are seeing large-scale demolition as the first step in building modern cities. In this jet-age, events move fast, faster indeed than we sometimes realize, and our progress is certain to be steady as we clear away the structures that block progress. In the 1950s, white residents had started to leave the city entirely. The departure was facilitated by the recent development of the highway system and by the GI Bill, which gave white veterans easy access to home loans while largely denying
城市还在为像大拱门这样的庞大新项目推平黑人社区。这是城市更新的时代。“我们越来越多地看到大规模拆除作为建设现代城市的第一步。在这个喷气时代，事件发展迅速，确实比我们有时意识到的还要快，当我们清除阻碍进步的结构时，我们的进步必然是稳定的。”20世纪50年代，白人居民开始完全离开城市。这种离开得益于高速公路系统的最新发展和《退伍军人权利法案》，该法案使白人退伍军人能够轻松获得住房贷款，而很大程度上拒绝了
black veterans the same right. White flight was happening all over the country, and St. Louis was no exception. As whites rushed to the suburbs, the city's population declined and its tax revenues plummeted. By the 1970s, African Americans with the means started moving out of the city too. We lost over a half a million people in this city since 1950, so we have a huge problem with vacancy. Andrew Wile again from the Landmarks Association. And at the same time, the neighborhoods that are vacant were built of incredibly high quality materials, incredibly durable materials. Most of the brick that's being stolen in St. Louis is, you
黑人退伍军人同样的权利。白人外迁在全国各地都在发生，圣路易斯也不例外。随着白人涌向郊区，城市人口减少，税收收入暴跌。到20世纪70年代，有能力的非裔美国人也开始搬离城市。“自1950年以来，我们这座城市流失了超过50万人，所以我们面临着巨大的空置问题。”地标协会的安德鲁·怀尔斯再次说道。“与此同时，这些空置的社区是用质量极高、极其耐用的材料建造的。圣路易斯被偷走的大多数砖块，你知道，都有100或120年的历史了，所以它们实际上才刚刚处于寿命的初期。”
know, 100 or 120 years old, so it's really at the beginning of its lifespan. Bricks can last for hundreds of years. The fallout from decades of racist housing policies and disinvestment in the North Side has created communities where the bricks themselves are worth more than the homes they support. The only reason these buildings can be stolen is because they are perceived to have no value. So if the building is perceived to have no value and their eyes watching it, you know, it's a perfect opportunity for it to disappear. By the time Sam Moore had become older men in 2007, Brick theft had already been going on for decades, but there hadn't been much of an effort by the city to stop it.
砖块可以持续数百年。几十年来种族主义住房政策和对北区的撤资所带来的后果，创造了一些社区，那里的砖块本身比它们支撑的房屋更有价值。这些建筑能被偷走的唯一原因是因为它们被认为没有价值。所以如果建筑被认为没有价值，而且没人看管它，你知道，这就是它消失的绝佳机会。当萨姆·摩尔在2007年成为市议员时，砖块盗窃已经持续了几十年，但市政府并没有做出多大努力来阻止它。
So Moore set out to figure out who was stealing bricks and how. To start, he did what any gum shoe would do. He went on some stakeouts. I watched him steal the bricks and followed them to the brick yard where they sold them and wonder why, which is city that an illegal organization like that of a business by brick. These brick thieves have found that abandoned houses represent remarkably easy targets. So easy that sometimes people are coming in from as far away as Las Vegas to steal them. It's not actually hard to tear the buildings down. People
于是摩尔着手调查是谁在偷砖以及如何偷的。首先，他做了任何侦探都会做的事。他进行了一些蹲守。“我看着他们偷砖，并跟着他们到了他们出售砖块的砖场，想知道为什么，一个像砖块生意这样的非法组织……”这些砖块窃贼发现废弃房屋是极其容易的目标。太容易了，以至于有时人们甚至从远在拉斯维加斯的地方赶来偷砖。拆除建筑其实并不难。人们
go about it in a few different ways. So the guy get up at 6 o'clock in the morning and get on a bicycle and take a screwdriver and pick him out six or seven bricks out of the wall and then snatch the wall. That's all it takes. Make a hole in the wall, slide a metal pipe in the hole, attach it to a chain, give yourself enough clearance and pull. Instant demolition. The thieves had figured out how to steal bricks even in busy areas. They just take out the back wall of the house, hidden from view. Like this is a busy street, so what they did was, they took the back out of this one.
用几种不同的方式来做。“所以那家伙早上6点起床，骑上自行车，拿一把螺丝刀，从墙上抠出六七块砖，然后把墙拽倒。”这就是所需要的全部。在墙上开个洞，把金属管滑进洞里，系上一条链子，给自己留出足够的空间，然后拉。瞬间拆除。窃贼们甚至想出了如何在繁忙地区偷砖的方法。他们只是拆掉房子的后墙，避开视线。“就像这是一条繁忙的街道，所以他们所做的是，他们拆掉了这一栋的后墙。”
Look to your right. Oh, I see you. You're right. So literally like the whole building is, the back of the building is gone and there's a tree that's grown up in it. Right. But you're right, the whole building is just the back of the building is gone and there's a tree that's grown up in it. Right. But you're right, the whole building is just, there's nothing there in the back.
“往右看。哦，我看到了。就在右边。所以字面上就像整栋建筑，建筑的后部不见了，还有一棵树在里面长了出来。对。但你是对的，整栋建筑只是建筑的后部不见了，还有一棵树在里面长了出来。对。但你是对的，整栋建筑只是，后面什么都没有了。”
There are various ways to steal an entire wall of brick. Some people will run a cable through one window and out another, and attach it to a truck and pull. Or they've used backhows that were contracted for other legal demolition jobs. They would drive them over in the night, knock down an abandoned house, and then return later to steal the bricks. One of the more drastic methods of stealing bricks involves burning the buildings first. The fire destroys the wooden supports holding up the building and weakens the mortar between the bricks.
偷走整面砖墙有多种方法。有些人会把电缆穿过一扇窗户，从另一扇窗户穿出，系在卡车上拉。或者他们使用为其他合法拆除工作承包的挖掘机。他们会在夜里把它们开过来，推倒一栋废弃的房子，然后稍后再回来偷砖。偷砖最极端的方法之一是先烧毁建筑。火灾会摧毁支撑建筑的木质结构，并削弱砖块之间的砂浆。
When the fire department would arrive to put out the fire, their high pressure host is often knocked down the walls and even clean the mortar off the bricks. Michael Allen is a preservationist who used to live in North St. Louis back in 2008 when Brick theft was at its worst and dozens of buildings were being stolen each month. I had personally worked with some neighbors. We boarded up buildings that weren't boarded
当消防部门赶来灭火时，他们的高压水枪经常会冲倒墙壁，甚至把砖块上的砂浆冲洗干净。迈克尔·艾伦是一位保护主义者，他曾于2008年住在圣路易斯北区，当时砖块盗窃最为严重，每个月都有几十栋建筑被偷。“我曾亲自与一些邻居合作。我们用木板封住了那些没有封住的建筑，
because we weren't waiting for the city. We nailed shut the doors to keep people out of them from setting the fires inside and then you know they'd be on fire. It didn't seem real driving home to go get groceries and pass like these buildings and it been stolen seemed otherworldly. Stealing the buildings is back breaking work and it can be dangerous. In a couple of times we have found people upside down in the rubble that they got caught. The bricks caught them and killed them. Eventually Alderman Moore got fed up with sitting in his car and watching all this happen to his neighborhood.
因为我们不想等市政府。我们钉死了门，防止人们进去在里面纵火，然后你知道，它们就会着火。”开车回家去买杂货，经过这些建筑，看到它们被偷走，感觉很不真实，仿佛超脱于世。偷建筑是极其辛苦的工作，而且可能很危险。“有几次我们发现有人被压在瓦砾中，他们被抓住了。砖块压住了他们并杀死了他们。”最终，市议员摩尔厌倦了坐在车里看着这一切发生在自己的社区。
So he started to confront the thieves when he would find them. People have been warning me, man, saying they got gunned. They don't like you. You need to stop running up on people. So I took his advice. I stopped running up on him. More eventually realized his interventions weren't making much of a difference anyway. Brick theft is classified as a nuisance crime, kind of like breaking windows in an old building. It carries a maximum $500 fine
于是他开始在发现窃贼时与他们对质。“人们一直在警告我，伙计，说他们有枪。他们不喜欢你。你需要停止冲向别人。”所以我听了他的建议。我不再冲向他们了。摩尔最终意识到他的干预并没有产生多大影响。砖块盗窃被归类为滋扰犯罪，有点像打破旧建筑的窗户。它最高可处以500美元的罚款，
and up to 90 days in jail. And given the amount of money that could be made selling stolen brick, a lot of people figure it's a risk worth taking. To me, what makes used brick so special and desirable is the color. This is Barbara Buck. She owns Century Used Brick.
以及最高90天的监禁。考虑到出售被盗砖块可以赚到的钱，很多人认为这是一个值得冒的风险。“对我来说，让旧砖如此特别和令人向往的是颜色。”这是芭芭拉·巴克。她拥有世纪旧砖公司。
It's a brick yard in St. Louis. And so when they tear the building down, you'll get like this mix of colors of oranges and reds, and it's really hard. It's been really hard for new brick manufacturers to duplicate that. Buck says her brickyard is scrupulous about only buying legally salvaged brick. They typically buy from just a handful of trusted vendors. Because we're legal, we have to know exactly where our brick comes from. legally salvaged brick. They typically buy from just a handful of trusted vendors. Because we're legal, we have to know exactly where our brick comes from. So if we don't usually have people showing up at our yard with just a palette, you know, trying to sell
这是圣路易斯的一家砖场。“所以当他们拆除建筑时，你会得到这种橙色和红色的混合色，这真的很难。新砖制造商真的很难复制这一点。”巴克说，她的砖场非常谨慎，只购买合法回收的砖块。他们通常只从少数几个值得信赖的供应商那里购买。“因为我们是合法的，我们必须确切地知道我们的砖块来自哪里。所以我们通常不会有那种带着一托盘砖块出现在我们院子里的人，你知道，试图卖掉……”
a palette. But Buck says there are other brick buyers that aren't as careful as she is. There was a guy in St. Louis that people were, he was buying brick, you know, after hours, one in the morning, you could get a shopping cart, fill a full brick, go get money, and go buy your drugs. And he was doing a huge business. And then the police shut him down. Buck explained to me that the supply of legally salvaged bricks is driven mostly by city-funded demolitions. So when the city runs out of money to tear down old buildings, more brick yards are willing to turn a blind eye to brick acquired illegally. And so that's when it gets, you know, tempting to, for these guys to steal brick and sell
一托盘。但巴克说，还有其他砖块买家不像她那么小心。“圣路易斯有一个家伙，人们在……他在下班后买砖，你知道，凌晨一点，你可以拿一个购物车，装满砖块，去换钱，然后去买毒品。他生意做得很大。然后警察查封了他。”巴克向我解释说，合法回收砖块的供应主要由市政府资助的拆除工程驱动。所以当市政府没钱拆除旧建筑时，更多的砖场愿意对非法获取的砖块睁一只眼闭一只眼。所以这就是为什么，你知道，对这些人来说，偷砖并卖掉它变得很有诱惑力，
it because they know there's a lot of demand and no supply. Some of the brick, whether it's legally salvaged or not, goes to building or renovating new homes in St. Louis. But most of it heads to another part of the country entirely. I would say most of it goes to Louisiana. And we sell some in Florida, we sell some in Mississippi, we sell in Texas. So there's, you know, southern markets
因为他们知道需求很大，而供应不足。有些砖块，无论是否合法回收，都被用于在圣路易斯建造或翻新新房。但大部分砖块完全流向了全国的另一个地方。“我会说大部分流向了路易斯安那州。我们还在佛罗里达州卖一些，在密西西比州卖一些，在德克萨斯州卖一些。所以，你知道，南方市场……”
that really love our brick. I'm 63 years old. I've been doing this since I was 18 and I've seen and heard just about anything you can think of in the brick business. Gary McConnell owns McConnell brick in Baton Rouge, Louisiana and he's been buying salvage brick for decades. When demand was at its highest, he was getting box cars full of used brick from St. Louis. New brick might sell for around $350 per thousand. Old brick, on the other hand, will go for almost two times that. For example, we sell St. Louis brick for 675 thousand. There are a few reasons why there's such a high demand for salvaged bricks in the southern United States, where McConnell's from. For one thing, in the 1960s and 70s, as neighborhoods in St. Louis were starting to hollow out,
真的非常喜欢我们的砖块。“我今年63岁。我从18岁起就做这个，在砖块生意中，你能想到的任何事我都见过、听过。”加里·麦康奈尔拥有路易斯安那州巴吞鲁日的麦康奈尔砖业公司，他几十年来一直在购买回收砖块。当需求最高时，他会从圣路易斯收到装满旧砖的火车车厢。新砖每千块售价约为350美元。另一方面，旧砖的售价几乎是新砖的两倍。例如，我们以每千块675美元的价格出售圣路易斯砖。在美国南部，也就是麦康奈尔所在的地区，对回收砖块的需求如此之高，有几个原因。首先，在20世纪60年代和70年代，随着圣路易斯的社区开始空心化，
a new style of architecture in the South was creating a market for used brick. We had an architect in Louisiana named Ahay's town, and he was the first person that I know of, and I was a kid back then, but he started designing houses using salvage material. Town was influenced by Antibellum Southern architecture. Of course, you know, we're down south, we have plantation homes, all those old, old plantation mansions and stuff, the brick were actually made on site. By enslaved workers living on the plantation. And they would make the brick and put them on these houses.
南方的一种新建筑风格正在为旧砖创造市场。“我们在路易斯安那州有一位建筑师叫阿海斯·汤恩，他是我认识的第一个人，我当时还是个孩子，但他开始设计使用回收材料的房子。”汤恩受到战前南方建筑的影响。“当然，你知道，我们在南方，我们有种植园住宅，所有那些古老的种植园豪宅之类的，砖块实际上是在现场制造的。”由居住在种植园的被奴役工人制造。他们会制造砖块并把它们用在这些房子上。
So when Mr. Town, his reputation and his flier was to replicate some of these old plantation homes. So the only way that you could do that was to use antique brick. Towns' designs called for used brick, not just for the facades of homes, but for the flooring, courtyard patios, and pool decks. Even today, some neighborhoods in Baton Rouge require all new construction to use reclaimed brick. Demand for that weathered look has gotten so high that only the wealthiest homeowners
“所以当汤恩先生，他的声誉和他的风格是复制一些这些古老的种植园住宅。所以你唯一能做到这一点的方法就是使用古董砖。”汤恩的设计要求使用旧砖，不仅用于房屋的立面，还用于地板、庭院露台和泳池甲板。即使在今天，巴吞鲁日的一些社区也要求所有新建筑必须使用回收砖。对那种风化外观的需求已经变得如此之高，以至于只有最富有的房主
can afford to have salvage brick. They're expecting to have salvage brick or, you know, old brick floors or pine beams or pine flooring, any kind of antique salvage stuff. They're expecting to see that in those upper-end houses. Aside from this desire for an antique look, there's another reason why so much use brick from St. Louis is headed to the Gulf Coast and out west. It's because not all bricks are created equal. The exterior layer of brick, the face brick, produced in St. Louis, is fired in such a way
才买得起回收砖。“他们期望有回收砖，或者，你知道，旧砖地板或松木梁或松木地板，任何种类的古董回收材料。他们期望在那些高端住宅中看到这些。”除了对古董外观的渴望之外，还有另一个原因导致如此多来自圣路易斯的旧砖流向墨西哥湾沿岸和西部。这是因为并非所有砖块都是生而平等的。在圣路易斯生产的砖块外层，即面砖，其烧制方式
that it helps it withstand the freezing winters in the Midwest. Interior brick is softer and can't stand up to the elements. In the 1960s and 70s, St. Louis home builders in the suburbs who started using reclaimed brick from the city got a nasty surprise. The brick facades were crumbling away. If you're going to put used brick on a new home, there has to be someone at the demolition site separating out the face brick from the interior brick That's something demolition companies can't or won't pay for
使其能够抵御中西部寒冷的冬天。内部砖块较软，无法抵御自然环境。在20世纪60年代和70年代，圣路易斯郊区的房屋建筑商开始使用从城市回收的砖块，结果遇到了一个令人讨厌的惊喜。砖块立面正在崩塌。“如果你要在新房子上使用旧砖，拆除现场必须有人把面砖和内部砖分开。”这是拆除公司不能或不愿支付的费用。
The easiest thing for them to do is just ship all of the bricks down to warmer climates where even the softer ones can be used on the exteriors of buildings To me, there's something sad about the beautiful old houses on St. Louis being torn down to build beautiful old-looking houses somewhere else. Barbara Buck, who runs the St. Louis Brickyard, agrees. You know, there are just times when I'll go to a building that I know is coming down. And I just feel so sad because I think about the family. You know, I'm very sentimental. I think about the family that lived there.
对他们来说最简单的事情就是把所有的砖块运到气候更温暖的地方，在那里即使是较软的砖块也可以用在建筑的外墙上。对我来说，圣路易斯美丽的旧房子被拆掉去别处建造美丽的仿古房子，这让人感到悲伤。经营圣路易斯砖场的芭芭拉·巴克表示同意。“你知道，有时候我会去一栋我知道要被拆除的建筑。我感到非常难过，因为我想到了那个家庭。你知道，我非常多愁善感。我想到了住在那里的家庭。”
I think about the family that built that house. I think about the generations that were raised in that house. But she's also practical. Many houses can't and maybe shouldn't be saved. We don't have the population. We don't have the jobs to support those houses. And everything has a lifespan. have the jobs to support those houses and everything has a lifespan. The worst of the brick theft is over today.
“我想到了建造那栋房子的家庭。我想到了在那栋房子里长大的几代人。”但她也很务实。“许多房子不能，也许也不应该被挽救。我们没有人口。我们没有工作来支撑那些房子。而且每样东西都有寿命。”砖块盗窃最严重的时期今天已经过去了。
Some of the brick yards that had a history of buying stolen bricks were shut down with the help of city workers, local activists, and representatives, like Alderman Sam Moore. Brick yards in St. Louis are now required to photograph whoever sells them brick, along with the demolition permit for that job. Now, the question is how to reinvent what's left behind. I'm doing a brick interview. A brick interview? You know I'm the brick man. Back in the Ville, Moore shows me some of the things they're doing with the vacant lots in the neighborhood. We pull up next to a fence decorated with life-size portraits of old Negro League baseball
一些有购买被盗砖块历史的砖场在市政府工作人员、当地活动家和像萨姆·摩尔议员这样的代表的帮助下被关闭了。圣路易斯的砖场现在被要求拍摄任何向他们出售砖块的人的照片，并附上该工作的拆除许可证。现在，问题是如何重塑留下的东西。“我正在做一个砖块采访。”“砖块采访？”“你知道我是砖块人。”回到维尔，摩尔向我展示了他们正在对社区空地做的一些事情。我们停在了一道围栏旁，上面装饰着1930年代黑人联盟棒球
players from the 1930s. Behind the fence is one of Moore's projects, an urban farm. This is called the Ville Archity. We've got about 50 fruit trees in it. We're growing tilapia fish. Oh really? And catfish. We've got a hatchery in there, we got chickens,
球员的真人大小肖像。围栏后面是摩尔的项目之一，一个城市农场。“这叫维尔拱门。我们里面有大约50棵果树。我们正在养罗非鱼。”“哦，真的吗？”“还有鲶鱼。我们在里面有一个孵化场，我们有鸡，”
we got the works. And there's new housing being built in the Ville too. But not the same kind of stately homes that the neighborhood used to be known for. It'd take a million dollars to build a moh houses over again. So we want mixed use in there, I think they look good. Anything that enhanced the neighborhood. Moore shows me some of the new houses. A traditional brick home in this neighborhood would have been made with walls that were three bricks deep. From the street, the new houses look kind of like the old ones, but up close you can see that there's something different. It's not a whole brick. It was a little clip-on gadgets. It's nice, it's a flat surface, it's about three quarters of an inch thick. It's a veneer of
“我们应有尽有。”维尔也在建造新住房。但不是社区过去以其闻名的那种庄严的房子。“重建那些房子需要一百万美元。所以我们想要混合用途，我认为它们看起来不错。任何能提升社区的东西。”摩尔向我展示了一些新房子。这个社区传统的砖房墙壁会有三块砖那么厚。从街上看，新房子看起来有点像旧房子，但近看你会发现有些不同。“这不是整块砖。它是一些小夹子。它很漂亮，是一个平坦的表面，大约四分之三英寸厚。它是……”
a brick. The clip-on brick works just like siding on a house. It's a slice of used or manufactured brick attached to the wooden frame of the building to give it that look of a brick home. factored brick attached to the wooden frame of the building to give it that look of a brick home. These homes with their brick veneer are far cheaper to build and will likely be the new face of the bill. They're not as ornate of the old turn of the century houses that used to define this neighborhood, but their affordability gets more people to move in to lower the vacancy rate, and that's what counts. Better to have a neighborhood full of life, even if the brick is fake and replace those dollhouses, with real houses. A lot of cities were ravaged by fire in the mid-19th century. St. Louis reacted by building
砖块的贴面。“这种夹式砖块就像房子的壁板一样。它是切片的旧砖或制造的砖块，附着在建筑的木框架上，给它那种砖房的外观。”这些带有砖贴面的房子建造起来要便宜得多，很可能会成为维尔的新面貌。它们不像过去定义这个社区的世纪之交的旧房子那样华丽，但它们的负担能力让更多人搬进来以降低空置率，而这才是最重要的。拥有一个充满活力的社区，即使砖块是假的，也比用真正的房子代替那些“玩偶屋”要好。许多城市在19世纪中期被火灾蹂躏。圣路易斯通过建造
everything with brick, but when St. Francisco burned down, it used brick in another novel way. We have a cool extra story about that after this. So a lot of other cities were also hit by fires in the mid-1800s, just like St. Louis. In 19th century, it was a very dangerous time in St. Francisco, for example, in regards to fire. People came out for the gold rush, lived wherever they could, in wood shacks, and tents, and even on wooden boats in the shallows of the bay. It was a disaster awaiting to happen.
所有东西都用砖块来应对，但当旧金山被烧毁时，它以另一种新颖的方式使用了砖块。我们在这之后有一个关于那个的酷炫额外故事。所以许多其他城市在19世纪中期也遭遇了火灾，就像圣路易斯一样。在19世纪，旧金山是一个非常危险的时期，例如，在火灾方面。人们为了淘金热来到这里，住在他们能住的任何地方，木棚、帐篷，甚至海湾浅滩的木船上。这是一场等待发生的灾难。
And critical studies here in the studio with me now, to talk about how fire shaped St. Francisco's architecture and infrastructure. In 1849, the same year that St. Louis suffered from a severe fire that ultimately turned them toward fire-proof brick, San Francisco was also hit by the first of a series of seven fires. And two years later, one of these destroyed and estimated 2,000 buildings, amounting to about three-quarters of the city at the time. And just so you know, the reason why there's a phoenix on the flag of San Francisco is
“现在演播室里有关键研究人员和我在一起，谈论火灾如何塑造了旧金山的建筑和基础设施。”1849年，也就是圣路易斯遭受严重火灾并最终转向防火砖的同一年，旧金山也遭遇了七场火灾中的第一场。两年后，其中一场火灾摧毁了估计2000栋建筑，相当于当时城市的三分之四。顺便说一下，旧金山市旗上有一只凤凰的原因是
because of all these fires of the 1850s. This is a little fun fact. But one of the things that's very clear is that San Francisco did not go the route of St. Louis. There are not a lot of brick buildings in response to the fires of the 1850s. Right. So brick was expensive out in the bay, and the climate doesn't really require the insulation or benefit from the thermal mass that brick provides. So a lot of the city was actually rebuilt using wood, but they did widen city streets to slow the spread of flames and they funded better equipped firefighting forces. The city even imposed a range of fines for any citizen who stood by and didn't help to put out future fires.
因为1850年代的所有这些火灾。这是一个有趣的小事实。但非常清楚的一点是，旧金山没有走圣路易斯的路。为了应对1850年代的火灾，那里并没有很多砖砌建筑。“对。所以砖块在海湾地区很贵，而且气候并不真正需要砖块提供的隔热效果或受益于其热质量。所以这座城市的大部分实际上是用木头重建的，但他们确实拓宽了城市街道以减缓火焰的蔓延，并资助了装备更好的消防力量。城市甚至对任何袖手旁观而不帮忙扑灭未来火灾的公民实施了一系列罚款。”
So they basically conscripted regularism to be involuntary firefighters? Yeah, it's amazing. Yeah, I don't know if that would fly today. No. But, and these fires, they also led to this creation of this underground system around the city, which provided water reserves for firefighters so they could tap the water closer to a blaze,
“所以他们基本上征召普通人成为非自愿的消防员？”“是的，太神奇了。是的，我不知道这在今天是否行得通。”“不。但是，这些火灾也导致了城市周围这个地下系统的创建，它为消防员提供了水储备，这样他们就可以在靠近火灾的地方取水，”
but the importance of these wouldn't actually be realized until about a half century later. You mean for the big San Francisco earthquake of 1906? Exactly. Water mains broke, rubble prevented fire fighters from reaching parts of the city, the fire ended up burning for days and thousands of lives were lost. And most of the city was destroyed. But in the aftermath, San Francisco set about expanding its auxiliary water supply system with reservoirs, pump stations, fireboats, and more earthquake-proof systems using concrete and steel, all which were designed
“但这些的重要性实际上直到半个世纪后才被意识到。”“你是说1906年的旧金山大地震？”“正是如此。水管破裂，瓦砾阻碍了消防员到达城市的部分地区，火灾最终燃烧了几天，数千人丧生。城市大部分被摧毁。但在余波中，旧金山着手扩大其辅助供水系统，包括水库、泵站、消防船和更多使用混凝土和钢材的抗震系统，所有这些都是为了……”
to help in emergencies when conventional water systems fail. Those also sound like very good solutions, but it doesn't sound like building with wood was a good idea still. Well, it was, and it wasn't. I mean, masonry is better for fires, but it's not as great in earthquakes. Right. Right. But all that being said, bricks did have a role to play. Walking around the city of today, you can spot where the city's sisterns are because they're marked out on the surface with big circles of bricks on San Francisco streets. So the bricks aren't actually part of the
在常规供水系统失效时的紧急情况下提供帮助。“这些听起来也是非常好的解决方案，但听起来用木头建造仍然不是一个好主意。”“嗯，是，也不是。我的意思是，砖石结构对火灾更好，但在地震中就不那么好了。对。对。但话虽如此，砖块确实发挥了作用。走在今天的城市里，你可以发现城市的蓄水池在哪里，因为它们在旧金山街道的表面上用巨大的砖块圆圈标记出来。”所以砖块实际上不是
sistern, but they do indicate where the sistern is. And visitors and new residents always ask about these are a huge mystery. What are those circle outlines that they're almost as big as a city street actually? Yeah, they stretch basically from sidewalk to sidewalk and they hint at something much larger below. Ultimately, they aid visibility in making these systems easier to spot in a crisis. And the middle of these brick circles are these little manhole covers that provide the actual access to the system. And being spread around the city These many reservoirs can function independently if quake damage cuts off one area from another and in total
蓄水池的一部分，但它们确实指出了蓄水池的位置。游客和新居民总是问这些是什么，这是一个巨大的谜团。“那些圆圈轮廓是什么？它们实际上几乎和城市街道一样大？”“是的，它们基本上从人行道延伸到人行道，暗示着下面有更大的东西。最终，它们有助于提高能见度，使这些系统在危机中更容易被发现。”在这些砖块圆圈的中间是这些小井盖，提供了进入系统的实际通道。而且分布在城市各处，这些小型水库如果地震损坏切断了一个区域与另一个区域的联系，它们可以独立运作，总共
They're about 170 of these spread around and they have a combined capacity of around 10 million gallons That's amazing Really is And so if you're walking through San Francisco, you should really look for them because they're quite cool And so if you're walking through San Francisco, you should really look for them because they're quite cool. Right, and I actually wrote an article titled The Coding Rings on our website, which talks more about the history,
大约有170个分布在各处，总容量约为1000万加仑。“太神奇了。”“确实是。所以如果你走在旧金山，你真的应该寻找它们，因为它们非常酷。”“对，我实际上在我们的网站上写了一篇题为《编码环》的文章，谈论了更多关于历史的内容，”
has images and videos, but most importantly, it has a map so you can actually hunt these down yourself if you want to. Oh, nice. And that website is? 99pi.org. Thanks. 99% invisible with produces weak by Zach Dyer, edited by Delaney Hall, Mix and Tech
有图片和视频，但最重要的是，它有一张地图，所以如果你想的话，你可以自己去寻找这些。“哦，不错。那个网站是？”“99pi.org。谢谢。”《99%隐形》，由扎克·戴尔制作，德莱尼·霍尔编辑，混音和技术
Production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer Kurt Colstead is the digital director, rounding out the team to Avery Chauvinman, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm.
制作由谢丽·福塞夫，音乐由肖恩·里尔。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监，团队成员还包括艾弗里·肖文曼、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎和我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心Radio Row制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下Radiotopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm找到它们。
We are supported by the night foundation and listener donors who pitch in whatever they can to keep us honest and keep us working hard. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. If you're thinking I need more 99PI in my life, well, we have all the old episodes available and new articles about design every couple of days on our beautiful website. It's at 99PI.org. Radio Tapio from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们得到了奈特基金会和听众捐赠者的支持，他们尽其所能提供帮助，以保持我们的诚实并让我们努力工作。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与关于节目的讨论。你可以在Twitter上向我发送推文@RomanMars，向节目发送推文@99PI org。我们也在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上。如果你在想“我的生活中需要更多的99PI”，好吧，我们所有的旧剧集都可用，并且每隔几天就会在我们的精美网站上发布关于设计的新文章。网址是99PI.org。Radiotopia，来自PRX。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。